hello hello you know this obnoxious
introduction by now I'm just saying what
I've read in the comments before you
face said we were know you're gonna get
this Samantha bee treatment you got to
apologize for that
Calista be she called Ivanka Trump the
c-word courageous yeah my name is
Margaret Cho no relation I am grace
helbig's born and I am a clitoris
troubles and iron man respond and today
we are Jewish jump in first of all
before we go any further I have to say
Margaret Cho thank you so much for
loaning me this stove alone I didn't
stole it
no I didn't stop Liddy that I paid full
price at Party City I never go in a shop
for clothes oh they have a wide variety
of clothing but I don't think it's like
appreciated enough oh but their wigs
look so cheap Sochi though it's gone I
would never buy a wig when we caught
dead if I was in a coma and you put a
party City wig on me do look wow
we're here because we sometimes we need
an outlet so we come here to charge our
computers and then while we're here we
sneak in and we set up a camera
equipment and then we film some sneaky
video so I put on our nieces YouTube
channels and today we have a
particularly appropriate I think it's
appropriate I think it's gonna blow up
the Internet I think it's Barris it's
gonna go viral article virus we know
that reality television it's a big deal
to a lot of people huge one of the
biggest reality shows we hear is the
Bachelorette I have never seen an
episode with it all but I have opinion
and the premise is basically a woman
gets to choose from like a gaggle of men
and she marries one of them and they get
like voted off every week or so
exactly and I have researched that this
bachelorettes name is Becca and her
tagline is let's do the damn thing
what that's big it is bacon also you're
gonna put a curse word on a poster on a
bottle sack so basically today clitoris
and I because we think we're great judge
of character we're going to review the
final contestants that are left in the
Bachelorette we're doing some on Grace's
Channel and we're doing some of our
Mary's channel so collapse so make sure
if you are done watching this video you
go immediately over to the other channel
and you watch that video because you're
not doing anything else
clearly you're unemployed summer job
rates a dwindling for your generation
but just saw the boat that's oh whoa I
know I shouldn't uncle punch you give me
enough your sandwich sorry I got you a
hungry it's so full there we go
okay we don't know anything about these
contestants but we're gonna judge them
based on exactly how they look which is
you know how society works so we're not
connected to the Internet okay okay here
we go oh wait no that's who went home
right Oh gone I don't want to see you
went hold on okay all right we got like
like crazy looks like Elvis
it's got a very rectangle head he looks
like a tiny rectangle on a bigger
rectangle I think he looks like a
rectangle he's a sales rep from Colorado
sales rep he's a mean like the drug
dealer
oh yeah Colorado marijuana marijuana lab
rat represents marijuana oh he does he
looks stoned he stoned like Yoanna oh
right what are you we got Chris food
sales trainer you saw both Lexus what
are you doing yeah training salesman
okay this looks like a Disney villain to
me he looks like he could be in like a
poker table with like guests on claw or
Scylla all right let the bill pay looks
like he deals poker cards we got drug
dealers we got poker dealers let's see
the next time next year
oh pro football player he's got kind
eyes but he also looks like he's never
seen a camera before yeah like someone
said hey clay and then he turned one to
go Heidi and then that caught on right
before I said hey also you and clay same
aesthetic
fashion wise who our best a very useful
30 the child's gonna say he's lying
that's a 34 year old man a 5 you think
so oh man oh I wish would they count the
rings around a stick corner almost like
a bitmoji 25 years old no way nice to be
marrying also a fitness coach I doubt it
well you does have a great head of hair
the wind swept it in the right way that
day yeah David David would look like a
mouse beside clay but also venture
capitalist sounds like a real job he's
also in Colorado so he does the weeds so
bunch of kappa's means he has that fit
in the weave the president of wheat I
have not seen you stoned since we went
to Jamaica shaked and ate an entire
sheet cake I got my entire hand braided
that lady I'm scared of it he looks like
he bites medical sales back what are
these weird vague fictitious job Lynette
was that medical weed there no
nevada-reno what you really do hear it
and that is scared children the only
carrot I want is mrs. Garrett from the
facts of life she was just so nurturing
Oh recipe Trudy I think oh yeah we got
Jason okay Jason scarier than the one
with the ski mask
I feel like we belong with the schema
all that if you ever don't know ski mask
that's true if you have a widow's peak
like that yes you got a great hairline
well yeah he's got the hairline of
Mickey Mouse john-boy
Jean blah he's a koalas in this all off
he's a dinosaur he's enjoying a soil I
think that's the thing you put up your
boy a co-op in the soil the yeah you get
a call just be okay
BA looking he gets poop on the poop
chute he takes the crap out of people
Jim didn't just leave his last name
empty blank
oh come on John that's not a real name
everyone knows John don't exist John's
don't exist 28 software engineer San
Francisco California
hanging out with all those hippies
summer love hey that's very what did you
just I'm sorry I had a flashback to 1967
when I went to the Summer of Love in San
Francisco and fell in love okay with
acid John looks like he's bitin all the
sides of his tongue yeah one looks like
he goes on a business trip and gets
focused
yeah he's got those eyes that look
pained after looking at all those dudes
I don't think any of them are good
enough Rebecca no granted I have no idea
what Becca's I have nothing of the face
that's on but I'm pissed I'm upset about
nothing and that's the way I've always
been and you wanna see more of these
contestants we got all of our very
candid reviews over on you deserve a
drink Mamie Ross YouTube channel machine
go check it out I deserve a drink after
this we all do make it off oh my god do
you think they thought we were being
mean I mean who gives us that they
signed up for the show I mean they
didn't get forced right they all
volunteered to do it right I was gonna
say did you think the people watching
thought we were mean and then I
remembered I don't care alright yeah
you're not short to a memory about the
your fear factor
[Music]
that cat the hangs on the tree but yeah
hang in there hang in there yeah it
could be like hang in there but it's not
that glass like the Scarecrow